on a vu tout ce qui était les relances
de jeu on part sur trois semaines
maintenant conservation malgré
l'excitation de pouvoir enfin reprendre
le championnat les entraîneurs du
rugby-club de versailles il veille à ce
que les joueurs gardent leur sérieux le
club qui évolue actuellement en fêtard
halle 3 se veut ambitieux pour cette
saison on a tout préparé on a eu le
temps justement de préparer
cette ses équipes l'objectif de cette
saison c'est
faire partie des trois quatre premiers
de poule pour jouer la qualification
pour jouer les premiers rôles dans son
championnat
le rcv a procédé à un recrutement ciblé
objectif renforcer son effectif avec au
compteur deux nouvelles recrues le poste
de première ligne qui était un poste un
petit peu un petit peu compliqué donc on
avait seulement recruté sur sur les
premières lignes
et après à chaque à chaque poste on a
essayé de d'agrémenter un petit peu par
par un joueur
en parallèle le club prenne toujours la
formation des jeunes et le beau jeu
comme élément clé de la saison
comme tous les ans le but du rcv c'est
de grandir grandir comme j'ai déjà dit à
chaque année c'est grandir avec sa
formation grandir avec ces jeunes
donc on a intégré déjà cette année
encore cinq juniors de l'année
précédente
déjà 200 entraîne un petit peu de se
démarquer du du groupe
le jeu là versailles et c'est un peu le
jeu rugby que tout vienne souhaite avoir
nous on restera sur cette directrice
c'est à dire voilà avec beaucoup
d'envolées beaucoup de prises
d'intervalles des prises initiative de
l'évitement et je pense que c'est comme
ça qu'on arrivera à atteindre nos
objectifs
cette identité de jeu s'est avérée
concluante le club versailles et a lancé
sa saison le dimanche 13 septembre par
une victoire 18 14 sur le terrain du rc
vin c'est la promesse d'un début de
saison à la hauteur des attentes